right-wing American website Breitbart
says it's got hold of emails which it
says shows Google staff plotted the
site's downfall by targeting its
advertising revenue for a quote hate
speech and fake news anyone want to hold
their nose and look through
breitbart.com for hate speech the emails
show Google employees discussing how
proving Breitbart users hate speech is
going to be tough and how the site's
very much on their radar and that
there's a moral argument to be had
the messages are dated the month after
President Trump took office which has
led to accusations of liberal bias
separately Google CEO this week defended
now the company handled search results
sent the US House Judiciary Committee
it's not possible for an individual
employee or groups of employee to
manipulate our search results you know
we have a robust framework including
many steps in the process American
International Studies professor Gerry
Sussman told us he thinks monopoly
structures like Google suppress
diversity in public opinion this raises
the whole question of free speech in
America which already is in decline
according to the Freedom House index
shows that the united states have been
steadily declining in in the Free Press
and other of their measures and other
indicators of free speech there has to
be space for diverse points of view and
that cannot happen when you have a
monopoly structure like Google you have
to have you just actually need to have
public service television for example
which may not which may or may not
really have a majority of viewers but
needs to be subsidized in some in some
fashion I think the same is true of
Google
there has to be it has to be broken up
it has to be fragmented and it has to be
structured in a way that allows very
diverse forms of use to have access and
to circulate in the country
you